mr. president thank you so much for take
it you know busy day I want I've better
viewed you a lot over the years I'm
gonna do something I've never done I
want to read the transcript because
everyone talks about whistleblowers not
whistleblowers gonna do that it's fine
you know
okay it says I'd like you to do us a
favor now you first talking about
congratulation right relationship like
you to do us a favor though because our
country has been through a lot
Ukraine knows a lot about it I would
like you to find out what happened with
this whole situation Ukraine they say
CrowdStrike and I guess you have one of
your wealthy people the server they say
Ukraine has it a lot of things that went
on the whole situation you say I think
that you're surrounding yourself with
some of the same people I would like to
have the Attorney General call you or
your people and I'd like to get to the
bottom of it and by the way so just so
you understand that's perfect and we're
looking at the 2016 election which was a
disaster
we went through hell my administration
people were destroyed their lives were
destroyed
not one person colluded they found no
collusion no nothing and they went
through hell there was a server the DNC
server that never went to the FBI the
FBI didn't take it it was taken by
somebody that I guess it's CrowdStrike
that's what I've heard and referring to
that that's not for an election that's
going into the future that's for a past
election that was a catastrophe and it
was a very unfair situation and after
two and a half years or two years they
found no collusion no nothing four
investigations Oh many many nights you
have house Intel bipartisan Senate and
the molar investors that's right
that's right many many investigations as
all they did as investigations and yet
we've had one of the most successful
administration's in history certainly in
the last two and a half years in the
first two and a half years of the
administration so when you look at
what's going on and then you see all of
this horrible stuff and then you hear
about Ukraine and you've been hearing
about it I heard Clinton was involved I
heard they got somebody who wrote the
fig dossier was it out of Korea out of
crane all of the things that happened
and I assumed that the Attorney General
I would like the Attorney General to
find out what's going on because you
know what we are investigating
corruption and I actually heard Gregg
Jarrett and numerous people the other
day say I have an obligation to do that
that's not a question can I do it or
don't I do it we have an obligation to
investigate corruption faith and that's
what it was in my opinion that that's
what it was is corruption and if Ukraine
would know something about the 2016
election you have to give that
information I hope that they would give
the information and everybody agrees
with me a hundred percent but when I
look at experts that are in your show
and other experts they're all saying you
have an obligation to do that so I think
you know I have a friend who is a very
good lawyer he read that conversation
it's not a letter it's a conversation
taken down and transcribed a perfect
conversation and you know so you know
who knows he actually said you did you
know this was going to be like a
document that's going to be analyzed I
said no but you have to understand I
assume there are many people it's either
being taped or it's being they either
have stenographers or taped and I think
they don't like to take world leaders
and I can understand that
so they have stenographers and people
that take this down transcribers and it
was a perfect transcription of a perfect
conversation the other thing is when I'm
talking to somebody world leaders are
almost anybody
I assume that State Department I think
Mike Pompeo is on I think many people
were on there many many people on do you
think I'm gonna say something wrong when
I feel that there's twenty five or
thirty or two or twenty or ten or
something but there are a lot of people
on these calls some I think listen for
educational reasons some listen because
they're members of the State Department
there are many people listening to these
calls and to think they took that call
now the big thing I did with that call
showed the biggest thing is immediately
released it because the whistleblower
came out and said horrible things about
this call I think they said there were
eight seven or eight quid pro quos it
was really a terrible call you know all
these
terrible things about this call I said
that wasn't a bad quote at all now what
else happened the president of Ukraine
came out and said that was a perfectly
fine call there was no pressure there
was no anything the the one of his top
people I guess one of his heads of state
came out and said this was a perfect
call there was no pressure they didn't
even know what we were talking about to
think that they're using that now they
don't talk about that anymore because
that letter was so good so they don't
talk about it anymore Sean and the
reason I don't talk about there's
nothing to talk about
the reason the next thing you say though
I think makes your point you say as you
saw yesterday the whole nonsense ended
with a very poor performance by a man
named Robert Muller an incompetent
performance but they say a lot of it
started with Ukraine whatever you can do
it's very important here's my question
and it did it ended with a very poor
performance and this is after more than
two years of an investigation where they
spent forty five million dollars or
something like that they had 2,500
subpoenas 500 witnesses all because
probably Hillary Clinton said just like
she did with Tulsi Gabbard just like she
did with Jill Stein she said Jill Stein
is a Russian asset no I don't know Jill
Stein I know her as an environmentalist
okay and probably a good woman the last
thing she is is a Russian asset
I don't know tulsi gabbard but I know
one thing she's not an asset of Russia
these people are sick there's something
wrong with that I want to show you this
I'll put it up on our screen for people
at home Ukrainian efforts to sabotage
Trump backfire this is this was January
11 2017 yep you weren't inaugurated yet
yep this article talks about how Ukraine
worked with Hillary to influence the
elections they give chapter and verse on
how they did it now don't you as the
president do you feel if there was
foreign interference in an election we
spent two and a half years hearing about
Trump Russia collusion they ignore the
dossier and Ukraine admitting that they
helped Hillary well the dossier was a
disk
the dossier was totally fake and now
it's been proven to be fake people know
how that was done I mean you'd have a
track record now you know as well as
everybody knows I guess they're doing an
investigation but I think before you
even do the investigation so they do a
fake dossier and me they tried to
release it before the election to effect
the election I don't know how they
didn't I say it's probably the only
thing I respect about the press is they
refuse to put it in before the election
because it could have had a little
impact maybe but I had more than a
little impact so they do a fake dossier
that was probably meant to get out I
mean I think definitely meant to get out
before the election so that they could
affect the election and look at the
people that wrote it and look at where
they came from
and look at the wife of the man that
works I won't even mention names at the
Department of Justice and she's on the
payroll of the company that Robert
Muller never heard of during his
testimony in GPS think of it never heard
of the company they said you know fusion
GPS he didn't know I didn't know what
was going on here
that's after spending 45 you didn't know
that Hillary Clinton's attorney at the
Clinton Foundation was on his team look
the whole thing was a disgrace and they
destroyed a lot of people they ruined
their lives and what went on was
absolutely corrupt and let's see what
ultimately happens let's see what a
position what happened to our country
again let me tell you short yeah this
should never happen to our country again
and this should never happen to a
president again look the Washington Post
which is a fake deal
The Washington Post puts out a story I
guess on Inauguration Day a few hours
after the inauguration day essentially
saying and now the impeachment begins so
this was a whole thing but one of the
worst things even before Muller was
struck in Page the two lovers where he
said or she said I guess he said that
she's gonna win 100 million to one she's
gonna win but if she doesn't we go to
the insurance policy when he said
insurance policy that means that right
now is the insurance policy okay
I thought it was over after the first
ridiculous thing with Muller but you
know what it's a disgrace when the
Washington Post comes out it says now it
begins now the impeachment and you see
every article is just no matter what you
do no matter how good you're doing and
nobody said better we have the best
economy we have the best unemployment
numbers the best employment numbers the
best we have the best of everything
we've rebuilt the military with all of
the things we've done regulation cuts
the biggest tax cut in history so many
things our energy were energy
independent now that's why you don't see
our boats being blown up over and the
girls you know so there's so many things
but they won't give you a decent article
no matter what you do it doesn't matter
it's a fix these are dishonest people
but when they say the impeachment now
begins Sean this was the day of the
inauguration have you seen I put a
montage together for television on this
show two days after you were elected
that word started we heard it all
throughout 2017
all throughout 2018 here we are here
meanwhile if it's collusion with the
government the Politico article said a
Ukrainian American operative who was
consulting for the DNC met with top
officials in the Ukrainian embassy in
Washington in an effort to expose ties
between Trump top campaign aid manna
fort and Russia this was before you that
happened interference happened and if
you look at the FBI they were doing work
on me from before the election ever took
place very early on John long before the
November 8 election they were doing work
on me and now with other senators or
other people in high office they would
say by the way I think you have a
Chinese spy working for you you know who
I'm talking about Dianne Feinstein had a
chauffeur that for many many years
worked for her and they went up to order
they said listen he may be a Chinese spy
and she fired him nobody told me
anything about that nobody ever told me
what they did is a disgrace and I really
mean it this should never happen to
another president
because what happened to people that
worked for me who are good people what
they had to do they went bust trying to
pay for their legal fees they came to
Washington to do a fantastic job I would
say they were bright-eyed and
bushy-tailed they came to Washington
they wanted to do great job on health
care on this on that on all sorts of
things and they left and they would dark
people they left dark and this was all a
phony scam and then you have Hillary
Clinton saying two days ago
Chelsea Kelsey Gabbard is a Russian
asset and that Jill Stein is a Russian
agent and I said wait a minute
it took me two and a half years I wish
you would have said that earlier because
people would have realized she's crazy
she's crazy but two and a half years
John we went through this and it started
before the election and President Obama
in September was told about Russian
influence and he didn't want to do
anything about it he didn't want to do a
thing about it because he assumed
Hillary was going to win so he didn't do
a thing about it nobody brings that up
nobody brings up his statement to the
President of Russia at the time nobody
brings it up as the whispers across
about I'll see you after the election
it's a very double standard it's a very
sad thing now you have a lot of people
from Clinton and from Obama and you also
have never Trump errs from Bush you know
I can't I can understand that Bush isn't
exactly loving me because we took on the
Clinton family and we took on the Bush
family and we beat them both you know -
I guess you'd call them dynasties right
if that's called a dynasty but we beat
them both and I would say they don't
exactly like me but we're doing a great
job
and with all of the things going on and
now to think it starts up again it it
was we beat it two or three times and
now it starts up again and this time
over an absolutely perfect phone call
with a very nice gentleman and when I
read it I said this is like a perfect
conversation I know it beforehand but I
wanted to say could I have possibly said
something wrong
so now what happens is I immediately
release it I release the conversation
okay so now we have a conversation
that's perfect and it's transcribed and
it's done by totally professional people
stenographers or whatever you would call
them so we have an exact conversation I
release it and now you don't hear from
the whistleblower anymore because the
whistleblower was talking about this
conversation in phony terms just like
Adam Schiff made up my conversation he
said seven or eight times think of this
Adam Schiff shifty chef he said seven or
eight times Shawn it was terrible seven
or eight times that I gave a quid pro
quo and I said not only seven or eight
times but there were no times because it
wasn't done okay I wasn't done he's a
corrupt politician and think of what
they're doing based on a very minor
conversation with the president of a
country who just got elected nice guy
visually a congratulatory conversation
the first pages you know congratulations
on your win etc etc couldn't have been
nicer I tell you Lindsey Graham said
when he read it he said wow I never knew
that Trump was that nice a person this
was such a nice conversation there was
no pressure it was a friend of yours you
know he said I've never seen I never
knew that he was so nice
meaning me I am viewed that as a
compliment in this case right but anyway
so look it's a disgrace what's going on
in the meantime we're doing a great job
running the country and that's what I'm
focused on running the country it's a
very unfair situation look at the double
standard though you got Hillary in the
dossier you got Ukraine interfering on
her behalf then you got shift who's been
telling us for three years lies and then
he's connected to the whistleblower so
he can't bring the whistleblower in then
you got they met with the whistleblower
nobody knew that we just found out they
knew and where is the person that gave
the whistleblower the information
because is that person a spy or does
that person even exist I have a feeling
that person doesn't exist I think Schiff
might have made it apparently shift
knows him and so does Joe Biden now the
funny thing is that they say they say
that the was
blower they don't need the whistle
blower anymore one of the new the
whistle blow you know why they don't
need the whistle blower because the
whistle blowers account of my
conversation was totally wrong
now they had no idea I was gonna release
the conversation and normally I wouldn't
I mean I'm talking to a foreign leader I
don't want to release a conversation
people are gonna want to talk to me or
any other president but that's what
happened and it's a disgrace so but I
want to go to the double standard again
whether it's the dossier whether it's
Ukraine helping and interfering on our
elections whether there is no quid pro
quo then you can add hunter Biden and
Joe Biden on tape bragging about using
taxpayer dollars to demand the firing of
the Ukrainian prosecutor hunter Biden
midst no experience Ukraine China no
experience in oil gas energy or private
equity throwing a millions of dollars
thrown out of the Navy yeah okay hunter
Biden was thrown out of the net why was
he given that money but anyone else that
way it's a payoff my opinion it's a
payoff why else would it be
look hunter Biden with no experience now
I hear the numbers 168 thousand a month
and I heard they got a three million
dollar just split between him and
another guy they get a three million
dollar payment and all of those okay
and that's corruption that something has
to be investigated that's what you have
to look but I watched this crazy
Anderson Cooper the other day during the
debate apologize for having to ask the
question to them apologist if that were
me he declared his innocence if that
were my son's that took 168 thousand
dollars from this very questionable
company an energy company and they knew
nothing about energy you know he knew
nothing about energy and he has a bad
record bad track record including
getting thrown out of the Navy and even
the way he got into Navy is interesting
in his position if that were Don junior
if that were Eric Trump were very
outstanding young men it would be the
biggest story of the century
what does it say about the media I agree
with these the media is corrupt
not all media's look I know some some
great people including you but I know so
great journalists look they Pulitzer
Prizes to people that got it wrong okay
all these people Fortuna from the New
York Times which is a fake newspaper we
don't even want it in the White House
anymore gonna probably terminate that in
the Washington Post a fake but you take
a look at the New York Times and you
take a look at the kind of reporting
they do it was all it turned out to be
all wrong and after the election the New
York Times apologized for their coverage
because they were covering me in such a
way so when I won
they actually apologized to their
subscribers because they were losing
thousands and thousands of subscribers
the New York Times wrote an apology
nothing else you know they're saying
well it wasn't really an apology it was
because they covered me so badly and
then what I said sort of interesting I
think I hope I said you know the good
news is now be covered fairly again and
you know what happened I got covered
worse I get covered worse but that's
okay you know reg tomorrow is the worse
they were made they say who Abraham
Lincoln I've heard the one person used
to be five or six now it's down to one
Honest Abe Lincoln they say you got the
worst press of anybody I say I dispute
it let me ask you so if the Democrats
has already jumped out of the plane
can't go back do you see a scenario
where they will impeach you there'll be
a trial in the Senate and then the
people get to speak would that be the
ultimate revenge which is your
reelection if the people speak so
everybody tells me it's going to be
great for us as a Republican party if
they actually impeach me because the 40
seats and there are many more than the
32 it's 4045 seats where I won or did
really well or very close that those
people are going to get hammered
meaning running in Congress so I don't
know if that's true or not I do say this
and I can see it because I've been I
mean look at our fundraising the money's
never come in like this look at my poll
numbers have been like the highest I was
in Dallas the other night we set a
record in a stadium I don't know it's
got to be an arena that's got to be 20
years old we have any lawyers a record
we had thousands of people outside
watching on big screens
they've never seen anything like that
but and it's that way at every place I
mean that was Dallas which we loved that
was great they did a great job great
place but it's that way everyplace look
at in Louisiana in Louisiana the other
night a governor was at 66
he couldn't get 50% and now you're gonna
have a runoff with a really great
Republican candidate look at North
Carolina great state great people two
races that we're going to be lost I went
in made a speech let everybody know I
really respect these two guys and
they're gonna be great they both won
they both won by good margins they both
won so I think the public is seeing it
actually let me ask you 2020s here all
right
you don't you said publicly you don't
think Joe makes it Drudge says Elizabeth
Warren it's hers to lose yeah Bernie
mayor Pete Kamala Harris whatever then
you look at their positions top marginal
tax rate 70% much higher 90% corporate
tax rate the new Green Deal 96 trillion
in ten years Medicare for all no private
options you comfortable running against
one of those who do you think it I don't
want to talk about it because you know
the last time I took on Elizabeth Warren
I thought she was gone
embers you know burning embers down
Pocahontas and polka there's only one
and it's not her okay so what happened
John and she rose from the ashes and I
give her credit for that but I don't
like talking about it as far as I'm
concerned the green New Deal it's fine
all of its fine paying ninety six
percent in taxes is all fine because I
want them to keep talking about it and
when it's time to run I'll run but I
don't want to talk him out of a Chuck
it's too early to talk about you know we
have can you believe we're getting down
to 12 months can you believe it when I
first won right in that corner of that
beautiful building and I was in the
first the first night with the first
lady and I'm standing in an area where
Abe Lincoln was all of them were and
that's the way it was and I'm standing
there and I say well for years that's a
long time and here we are we're almost
coming up but we have tremendous support
we've cut taxes we've cut regulations we
have great stock markets you know we
have over a hundred days and that's in a
fairly short period of time with the
stock much more than a hundred is with a
stock market hit an all-time high it's
about to hit it again we're doing great
and we're beating everybody all over the
world countries aren't doing well
China's not doing well China's having
the worst year they've had in 57 years
and we just made a deal for our farmers
we're 40 to 50 billion dollars worth of
agricultural products going to be bought
by China and they're gonna start now
before we even signed the agreement
they've already started but we've done
things that nobody else has done and to
go through this on a perfect
conversation you're gonna be impeached
to me impeach is a very ugly word it
really means a high crime and
misdemeanor that letter is a perfect
conversation with a man congratulations
on your win and to a peach over a letter
like that but they don't mention the
letter anymore and then I'll mention
whistleblowers and they don't mention
any of these people anymore the secrecy
though I want you to react Newt Gingrich
1998 did impeachment yeah they they were
due process yeah presidents attorneys
Kevin McCarthy spelled that out Pat's a
baloney your White House Counsel wrote a
pretty strong letter or good luck how
this inquiry is unconstitutional without
any due process and it's about undoing
2016 and influencing 2020 so what
they're doing now is something that's
never been done before they don't want
the facts to come out and by the way
from what everything I don't know most
of these people and if I do I do
I met him quickly or I know very little
but ambassadors and some others I don't
even know most of them I never even
heard of their names okay and they bring
them in and they're actually turning out
to be better witnesses by far for us but
no lawyers we have no lawyers
Republicans because it's the minority we
have no lawyers we can't question we
can't do a thing
we can't they can't even go into we
don't think Republicans have been tough
enough though you said that today I
think the Republicans should get tougher
look I think that the Democrats are not
good politicians I think they have lousy
policy
policy of open borders and sanctuary
cities and crime and you know brings all
of this crime and it brings drugs and it
brings well I think they're lousy
politicians they have horrible policy
but you don't have the Mitt Romney's of
the world you don't have people that
will go against the party you you have
better they stick together I respect
that the other thing is they're vicious
they're much more vicious we would never
do a thing like this
they could have impeached Obama for the
IRS scandal they could have Beach them
for the guns for whatever where guns
went all over the place and people got
killed if he was fast and furious they
could have killed him they could have
they could have impeached him for many
different things they didn't impeach him
they never even thought of impeaching
him here here think of this I've gone
through the impeachment now since the
beginning on Russia on mauler
or all this stuff okay and then they
come up with this crazy concept of a
perfect conversation I'm serious a very
good lawyer said you must have known
this is going to become a public
document because you spoke so nicely
this isn't that we're talking about
impeachment
to me the word impeachment is a dirty
disgusting word I didn't do a reason to
impeach the only reason they're
impeaching is because they look at the
polls and they see Moody's just came out
and said under all three scenarios Trump
wins easily 351 electoral votes they see
what's going on they see the level of
popularity when they look at Minnesota
Minneapolis was incredible when they
look at Dallas when they look at
Louisiana when they look at North
Carolina the two seats we just picked up
they see what's going on that's what
they're doing congressman Al Green a
Democrat said we have to impeach him
because he's gonna win this is what I'm
up against who would do this
who would play a dirty game like this
well obviously you know you talk about
it hurting the country he said we better
impeach him because he's we're not gonna
be able to beat him that was afraid
nobody believed the statement but by the
way there's more than just him that made
that statement
and you know when you do a Paul well
every Democrats gonna say hey we want to
win you Pete you go ahead it would be a
terrible thing for the country if they
did it because then if you have a
Democrat president and some day you'll
have this combination I guess if you
have a Democrat hopefully it's gonna
mean a long time but that's okay you
have a Democrat president you're running
six oh wait a minute
that makes the Matt that makes their
heads explode tell them we're running
for 60 yeah but listen John if you have
a Democrat as president and you have a
Republican House and you have a speaker
that's tough and crazy like Pelosi she's
crazy and if you have somebody like that
what happens is very simple like I say
let's impeach the president let's check
his phone calls oh gee there was a comma
put in the wrong location let's impeach
it supposed to be for high crimes and
misdemeanors I can't even believe that
this wouldn't be a lawsuit how can you
take a president up now again they don't
like to talk about the phone call
because it was perfect they don't like
to talk about the whistle Adam Schiff
said he doesn't want the whistleblower
anymore you know why because he might
have given the whistleblower the things
to say he'd have to answer questions
about Schiff and about his relationship
with Biden let me let me ask him more
about 20/20 record low unemployment
since 1969 when you ran you said what
have you got to lose
when you would speak to minorities right
well now you have record low
unemployment historic Hispanic Americans
Asian Americans African Americans women
in the workplace youth unemployment okay
what is your message to minorities in
2020 your base looks strong you can see
it at the rallies what do you say to the
people that maybe didn't vote for you
last time African American Hispanic
Asian American have all set records the
lowest unemployment in the history of
our country not just like for 50 years
we have 51 years for the country and
we're gonna end up topping that number
pretty soon that'll be historic to verso
if we keep going the way we're doing I
think we will yeah because the household
income is so incredible a median
household income but if you look
african-american asian-american Hispanic
American in the history of our country
they have the best unemployment numbers
and the
have the best employment numbers today
it was announced that we have the most
people working in the history of our
country almost 160 million people how do
you beat me in a debate on those numbers
okay they're the best numbers poverty
numbers are the best right now for
almost all of those groups poverty
numbers meaning in a positive sense but
in poverty poverty right people love
heart obsessed numbers in the history of
our country there's another number that
just came out and it came out I guess
with the Moody's report saying that I
would win easily the the Moody's report
was very interesting median household
income under eight years of Obama was up
nine hundred and seventy five dollars
that's eight years under eight years of
President Bush they have President Obama
975 President Bush four hundred dollars
eight years eight years four hundred
dollars nine hundred and seventy-five
dollars me two and a half years it's up
seven thousand dollars five thousand
dollars plus two thousand dollars for
the tax cuts that everybody got so you
had the two thousand to the five so you
got one up a thousand nine hundred and
seventy-five dollars the other ones up
four hundred but that's over eight years
each one i'm only here two and a half
years and i beat them by many times in
two and a half years what's that
percentage like proportionately so it's
up five thousand dollars plus two so
it's up seven thousand dollars median
household income that's a record there's
never been anything like that and then i
say oh let's impeach the president
give me a break sean i don't think the
people will stand for it i really don't
i don't think the people will stand for
as to whether or not it helps it might
because over the last word though in a
year you're running well these people
are supposed to be high crimes and
misdemeanors a perfect conversation what
would you Mitch McConnell said I have to
do this six weeks to put on a trial for
what for that transfer I can't imagine
that I can't imagine that they do it I
can't imagine I can see it being very
very bad for forty or forty-five people
that are Democrats in a district that I
when I
Rann I won very substantially in many
cases I won by a lot and I don't think
those people want to see this you know
it's one thing if you commit a real
crime this was a conversation it wasn't
even a big deal hey how you doing bah
bah bah this was a conversation that was
so perfect what people say it's like a
perfect conversation speak to Lindsey
Graham speak to all these people that
have read it impeachment is high crimes
and misdemeanors
I think it's a travesty for our country
they're doing such a bad thing to our
country and that's because the Democrats
are vicious and they stick together for
instance when you do a censure of on
Adam Schiff what did he do he made up my
conversation totally like fiction who is
it was fraudulent he made it sound he
took that conversation he made it sent
now he didn't know about that
conversation so he went up he made up a
phony conversation read it to Congress
read it to the American people and I
released that and that was the real
conversation so he then said oh I don't
know
it was already out it was parody yeah no
it was parody so this is a corrupt
politician he should be impeached Nancy
Pelosi should be in a page they should
not allow this with that it's possibly
going to help you know from the
standpoint of winning election I don't
know they say it's going to help a lot
with respect to winning the house back
but it's not the right thing let me ask
you about Syria and let me ask you about
Iran ranchoddas drone out of the air
they have taken tankers hostage you
mentioned energy independence the
Straits of Hormuz taking our tankers no
not ours but no straits or Muslim or
less geopolitically important very few
ships because since I came in we're now
energy independent right so we have very
few ships in fact that comment was made
the other day they don't see too many
American ships anymore so when you have
Syria you've gotten criticism well this
weekend it seems like you would lindsey
at an empress look we have the same name
no it sounds like you guys do one
definite probably want to bring the
soldiers back home well they were
supposed to be there for 30 days they're
there for 10 years
we're in Afghanistan there for 20 years
we're reducing those numbers very
substantially in Afghanistan but there's
supposed to be in Syria for 30 days now
one thing about Syria when I took over
Isis was all over the place you know
that better than anybody do and a half
years ago I went in and when I started I
got rid of that whole thing all those
prisoners all that those are my that
they were captured under Trump we killed
many many Isis fighters it it's you know
you hate to talk about caliphate was
where we killed we took a hundred
percent of the Caliphate a hundred
percent
everybody says that everybody so it's
not like oh gee Obama did it I'm I did
it but you know what it's now time to
bring our soldiers home and it's very
interesting that little fight for two
days vicious stuff I don't know the
turkey would have done what they did
like a ceasefire and I don't know that
the Kurds would have moved out but they
went through two days and I say and some
people thought it was a great analogy
some people know but it's like two kids
in a playground they fight you let them
fight for a minute and then you pull
them apart it was much easier to make a
deal you're willing to because you did
well two things number one you remove
the rules of engagement that President
Obama had to you didn't like you bomb
them you push them out and if need be my
guess is that I'm asking about the Trump
doctrine in a sense you'd go back
hundreds overwhelming force no rules of
engagement which to me is like putting
handcuffs on our military should I go to
Dover Air Force Base and I see young men
and women coming back in coffins I go to
a great Walter Reed Hospital way I think
you have the best doctors like in the
world these incredible military doctors
what they can do for these young people
and I see people young beautiful people
that such incredible stuff I was there
last Friday and I gave out Purple Hearts
so beautiful people but oftentimes
they're missing legs and they're missing
arms they're missing both
and I see the parents and I see the
heartbreak the devastation of the
heartbreak I signed letters right here
in this office
the Oval Office I signed letters to
parents no miss letters are saith from
no no to letters are ever the same way I
say you got to make them different you
know they compare them you know it's
interesting even though they may not be
in the same part in the same country
when they die at a certain time the
parents get together to celebrate their
their sons or daughters who were killed
it's an amazing I don't want them to
read a like a form letter we make every
letter different it's very important to
me it's something ask you this then we
start wars we politicize wars then we
get nervous politically and then it
seems that we put handcuffs on our
military Vietnam Iraq Afghanistan
everything gets politicized is the next
step maybe the Trump doctrine even that
the next generation of weaponry
offensive and defensive weapons will we
fight them from Tampa is so you spent a
lot of money on yeah well making the
most sophisticated weapons ever made
we're making the greatest missiles the
greatest rockets the greatest everything
ever made
are nuclear is now up to snuff at a
level that it's never been
we're actually ordering new nuclear
we're building right down new nuclear
not that I want to but as you know
Russia was not playing fair with us with
the treaty and we therefore terminated
it I believe that we're going to get
together with Russia and with China
whether it'll work out or a nuclear pact
so that we don't all continue with this
craziness right now we have the most
powerful nuclear force in the world
Russia is second and China's third it's
very costly and very dangerous it's very
very dangerous and we are discussing
with Russia and we're discussing with
China during the recent trade deal with
China I said we should all get together
and work out something a cap have a cap
we don't need 10,000 weapons have a cap
and I will say China and Russia in
talking about it are extremely excited
about we'd have
to have trust but verify though sure a
hundred percent we need all of them well
look I'm the one that terminated the
agree with a determined I terminated it
because we found them they were making
they were doing things that they weren't
supposed to be doing in the agreement so
we had an agreement a non-nuclear
agreement and we had all sorts of limits
and we were the only one that was paying
attention to it
that's not fair but now they know we're
a different country and I think Russia
would like to make a deal and I think
China would like to make a deal and I
think that's a big that would be a
terrific thing I'd love to be a part of
that I was surprised you didn't hit Iran
we have a lot of goodwill built up they
took down a drone there was nobody in it
they took down a second drone there was
nobody in it there's a lot of good will
they hit Saudi Arabia we sent troops
over to Saudi Arabia Saudi Arabia is
paying for it you know that's never
happened before we said look you got to
pay and they're paying it to me they
have nothing but money nothing but cash
they're paying but we sent some troops
over there we're gonna give him good
protection and we built a lot of good
capital up you know everyone thought
that when I got elected Hillary Clinton
used to say oh you'll have World War
three well I'm very tempered actually a
lot of people would have hit but I built
up a lot of capital by not hitting by
not hitting you understand that oh they
shot us all he did with the Caliphate so
you will in a throw I wiped out the
Caliphate and you also saw when I hit 58
rockets missiles right into the middle
tomahawks
right into the middle of of Syria and
knocked out a whole base it did which is
something by the way President Obama he
drew the red line in the sand and then
he didn't violate that red line and let
me just tell you when he didn't do it
that's when everyone else came in
including Russia last question I know
the whole issue a that was a big moment
oh yeah he said red line in the sand and
then something happened what they did is
they had chemicals and they destroyed
500 babies and children and everything
and he didn't do anything about it that
was a very bad moment for our country
but I did something because when I came
in I hit them very hard
[Music]
I've known you for a long time
yeah I'm you've already given the answer
earlier today on Darrell I won't go down
there you might move it a Camp David I
guess you're looking for another
location known you for a long time you
thrive on a battle you thrive on
fighting you've said to be privately and
publicly you want your promises
fulfilled and I guess that's what
reelection is going to be about all this
and peach and peach and going on do you
care you would you care at all what they
do as long as you win in November
does it matter to you except what you
said earlier about it hurts the country
okay look we've done a great job the
economy is the best that's ever been
ever been and you look again
China's gone way down if Hillary Clinton
had gotten elected right now China would
have the number one economy in the world
and right now they're not even close
they're way beyond we've picked up
trillions of dollars in worth and value
and China's gone way way down by
trillions and trillions of dollars when
the head of China spoke to me recently
and even the vice premier just left just
left this office right here last week he
said congratulations mr. president on
the incredible job he said we would
never have expected this to happen
don't forget China's paying us tens of
billions of dollars now in tariffs and
it's had a huge impact on China and it
hasn't cost us anything because they've
devalued their currency and they poured
money and it hasn't cost us and they've
eaten that they've eaten it totally but
he said congratulations on the job
you've done with the economy had Hillary
Clinton got in right now we would be the
number two economy in the world we are
so far in front of China that if we have
smart people sitting right in that chair
right next to us it'll never happen
I think you must negotiate everything
because I've known you for a long time
mr. president won't take any more of
your time thank thank you thank you sir
[Music]